what is your approach to addressing sex
to your children love you
oh
[Music]
it soda fixes your life
hi guys
it's sona i'm obsession and this is the
return of sona fixes your life
and as you can tell i'm very serious i
have books behind me
i've read every single one
that's a lie
and i have this thing next to me what is
this it's a rocker why do i know that
because i'm a parenting expert now how
am i a parenting expert i have had
children for four months
two of them so obviously i'm an expert
so i'm happy to answer all the questions
that you guys have about parenting so
let's raise your kids at euler 277 says
what are your strategies for keeping
conan away from your children
uh
just
to a never given my address
b
you know i told him i was pregnant but i
uh
i think that if i just tell him that i
was a pillow the whole time maybe he'll
never show up
so i guess that's the best way it's just
to never tell them where i live because
then i'll just come and want to meet
them at amprobius says what is your
approach to addressing sex to your
children love you
that's intense
sex
sex
i don't know do i tell them now is four
months too early to talk to them about
sex because then you just like
they'll just always grow up knowing
about it
so now
i'll be like when a man and a woman love
each other very much or
you know what no now when a man and a
man love each other when a woman and a
woman when someone is non-binary and
someone else is non-binary love each
other very much
parts go into other parts or sometimes
things rub up on each other
i don't
i have no idea how i'm gonna talk to
them about this stuff i think i'm just
gonna make my husband do it
i know how
things work
like the guy parts work
but i don't have an intimate knowledge
of it because i don't have
that
so i don't know i could i think i just
make tac do it i'll just make my husband
do it
he'll just do that he'll just do that
talk but i when what is your approach to
addressing sex to your children
make someone else do it and i love you
too at amprobius
dj esby says do you have any armenian
parent tips life hacks
yes i am that's cute i'm high too
obviously i knew what that meant there
have been a lot of uh armenian
opinions
floating around in this house and when i
say a lot i mean like every day there's
something
uh
there's obviously like 500 evil eyes in
my baby's nursery to protect them
uh
we
you know there's there one of them had
like an umbilical hernia where his like
belly button stuck out a little
and so we taped a quarter
to his belly button to flatten it
a quarter it was wrapped up and we taped
a quarter and you know what that [ __ ]
worked it worked i mean it's a little
off-putting to tape anything to your
newborn child but it worked at yuki d
nakamura says not a parenting question
but is your dog still number one or did
your kids take that spot i don't know
okay who's my favorite who's my favorite
oaky who's my favorite oogie who's my
favorite who's my favorite who's my
george
let's just say i know where my dog is
and i don't know where my boys are
[Music]
oh my god she's so soft
i love you so much
i love you so
much i love you so much